russia is pulling back its forces north
of ukraine's capital but that has
brought horror rather than relief as
indications of a civilian massacre come
to light the devastating images from the
town of bucha indicate that putin's
forces murdered hundreds of civilians
before withdrawing that's sparking new
calls for harsher sanctions including an
embargo on russian fossil fuels
so far germany's been resisting fearing
massive harm to an economy highly
dependent on russian gas the predicament
is prompting a new look at politicians
who enabled that dependence and we're
asking russian war crimes the end of
german illusions
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to to the point it's a pleasure
to welcome our guests malta laming is
author and lead editor at the berlin
daily tag spiegel
and it's a pleasure to welcome matthew
karnichinig he is chief europe
correspondent for politico
and also glad to have with us claudia
kempfat she is head of the department of
energy transportation and environment at
the german institute for economic
research
and i'd like to start by talking a
little bit about what we think is
happening on the ground and matthew
what's your interpretation of the
russian troop pull back what do you
think putin's next move could be
well it certainly looks like he's trying
to regather his troops strength and
reposition them in the east to
kind of launch a new attack from the
east and and get what they can because
it was clear that they weren't going to
succeed in
in uh surrounding kiev and and taking it
over so i think uh they're they're
regrouping as it were and
it's something the ukrainians are
certainly worried about because they've
been fighting russia in the east
obviously for the past for the past
eight years
claudia
ukraine possesses the second largest gas
reserves in europe and much of that is
in fact in the eastern part of the
country leading some experts to conclude
that putin may well be looking to
establish full control over those
reserves is this war ultimately all
about fossil fuels yeah we are in the
middle of a fossil fuel war and that's
for sure because russia has the largest
reserves on oil coal and gas on earth
and also there is an interest clearly an
interest in also
having the gas or using or
exploring the gas that is located in the
ukraine so for sure there might be one
reason it's not the pure reason or the
first reason but there is a reason and
fossil fuel plays a key role in here
at any rate the russian reorientation of
troops uh has now allowed these images
to come to light from the town of butch
images that appear to show that a
civilian massacre occurred there malta
back in january prior to the beginning
of the war you warned against western
weapons deliveries to russia saying they
could cause putin to take even harsher
aggressive aggressive
moves
do you think that's what we're seeing
here in these images from from butcher
no things have changed i mean if you
start a war there's a different logic so
i would be in favor now of weapons
delivery uh to the ukraine so that they
can act in self-defense self-defense is
something else then preparing for a war
and preparing for a war you have
different kind of logic
so what happens now i think is a is a
battle as well about fossil fuels but
about the black sea i mean we have the
the crimean in the black sea we have
odessa we have mario paul all these all
these centers surrounding and the black
sea is so delicate because we have two
nato members bulgaria and romania with
huge borders to the black sea nato could
have uh
could drive into the black sea but then
they will be confronting russia so
this will be a very very delicate moment
of in the next weeks to come
we also
know of course that russia has been
laying siege to maria paul we don't yet
know the full extent of
damage and
and killings there but
matthew if you look at these images from
butcher which of course are only
possible because the russian forces had
withdrawn how certain can we be first of
all that it was russia that committed
these murders and secondly that this
amounts to war crimes
well i think we have to start by saying
that you know what war crimes are always
very difficult to prove in court
but
i think to any thinking person we also
you know have common sense and if you
look at the evidence there if you look
at the satellite images taken before the
russians left that the new york times
has studied and confirmed show the
bodies were lying there on the street
before the russian troops left i think
it's pretty clear that number one war
crimes were committed there can be no
doubt about that and i
would say it's very very likely that the
russians are responsible for this i
don't think that any you know
person who looks at the evidence
objectively could come to to another
conclusion at this stage whether that
can be proved in court of course is is
another matter but i think that the west
has to react to this
assuming that russia
is responsible and i think that's what's
what's happening now although you know
many western governments still aren't
willing to go as far as ukrainians would
like i think as the americans would like
in terms of imposing an embargo on
russian gas for example which is
something that germany austria other
countries in europe are resisting and
let's in fact listen to what uh
one ukrainian has had to say after the
images emerged from butcher ukraine's
president traveled there and delivered a
ringing condemnation of what in his view
amounts to european appeasement of
vladimir
and see what the policy of concessions
to russia has led to in 14 years
to see with your own eyes the tortured
ukrainians and ukrainian women ukraine
[Music]
malta noteworthy that president
zielinski named names there named
chancellor mackel named president macron
how is the german political elite
reacting
um
i i think some of them understood
uh what has happened and what kind of
mistakes they made it's very very few
in the elite i think
a country that decides to phase out of
nuclear energy
and out of coal
um and is not able to to be fast enough
in building renewable energies like wind
turbines and and things like that they
need fossil fuels they need the gas
and that's what they did for the last 15
years by by deciding to phase out of
these things you you enhance the the
need for that and you enhance the
dependency on gas things so that's why
white putin was um was financed by all
these imports
and his in his military buildup was
financed by germany so i think this is
what zelinski understands and what he's
always pointing at to say this has to
change let me ask you this if i may
chancellor mackel although to some
degree she was also tough with putin
after 2014 she held europe together on
sanctions against russia on the other
hand she stuck with the nordstrom 2 gas
pipeline right to the end and she
remains veiled in silence she has not
addressed
the
reassessment of her legacy that many
people are demanding yes i mean um
she was the one who decided after the
the earthquake and fukushima
to speed up uh to go out from atomic
from nuclear energy so what is the
result if you don't have enough right
now we we still have just 40 percent of
our energy coming from renewables
and if we speed that up we will in very
very short time have the so-called nimby
effect not in my backyard things that
people will stand up and say not in my
backyards i'm in principle i'm in favor
of renewables i want to come back to
that but i'd like to stay with the
reaction right now uh two accusations
like the ones that we heard from
president zielinski there claudia i
think you wanted to speak to that or to
the energy issue to the energy issue
because at the same time when this
happened also that what you said that
the increased dependency on russian gas
there has been barriers established to
reduce the share of renewable energy we
could have today a share of renewable
energy of 80
if we would have not blocked this
development and that is you don't need
gas gas was never a bridge technology
it's by purpose and it has been a
political reason why it happened in this
way so there is a clear
reason why north stream 2
has been established there is a clear
reason why we do not have an full energy
transition yet which we could have had
if we would have been much faster
i really want to drill deeper
but
on
the
on the on the policy of both it depends
of america's policy
the second part of the answer is our
relationship to russia i mean uh germany
killed like 27 million inhabitants of
soviet union russians bill russians
ukrainians
and during the second world war
and they had they had the feeling that
because unification what they never
believed it was possible because of the
soviet russia that unification with
russia they owe something i mean we
still still remember the gorby gorby uh
uh enhancement when the wall came down
gorbachev was meant and the love of
gorbachev the love of russia that they
made it possible
and forget that they even paid them for
for pulling back their troop with 18
billion marks to that german march at
that time have you ever seen a country
that was occupied and paying the
occupier for for going for pulling back
that was the german relationship to
russia and let me ask you matthew
because you recently just a few days ago
wrote an article called putin's useful
german idiots in which you said and i
quote uh putin's invasion of ukraine is
a repudiation of a whole generation of
german politicians tell us why
well i think we're sort of seeing that
play out here and with with merkel
obviously gerhard schroeder who was one
of the fathers of north stream two
former german chancellor who actually
even now recently traveled to moscow uh
to redeem himself
one and two nordstrom wanted to who went
straight from the chancellery a few
weeks later joined um
the board of north stream as it's as its
chairman
um so i i think if you if you start to
stand back and look at this scenery in
germany you can see that the major
figures in both parties it's not just
one party it's not just
it's not just the social democrats it's
the two dominant political blocs in
germany are complicit in this decision
and i would also argue that it goes
beyond that even into the media
establishment especially in the uh the
public media in in germany that also
stood behind these policies uh if if you
go and listen to the commentaries just
from a couple of years ago you heard
people saying well we shouldn't be too
hard on russia you know the the nato is
saber-rattling as now president
steinmeier said back in 2018 when there
was a nato exercise
in in eastern eastern europe 16. uh so
you know these are these are all things
that that point to a kind of group think
here that i think led us to this point
and i think that they're they're they're
in shell shock now all of these
politicians don't know what to do and i
think this is the the crisis really that
germany faces because it can't lead at
this moment because it's been
discredited federal president uh
frankfurt steinmeier has actually now
admitted to having made grave grave
mistakes
do you think the scales are finally
falling from german eyes and will it
make a difference
unfortunately i don't and if you
actually look at the text of what he
said he uses the plural a lot and says
you know i like many others
uh and you know if
if you look at what he actually said
he's he's essentially saying our
strategy was right but putin didn't play
along and you know putin is really a bad
person uh whereas if you go back in time
you know this was very controversial
internationally in germany's relations
with other countries there were plenty
of people outside of germany saying you
can't trust putin look at what he's done
in georgia look at what he's done in
syria look at what he's doing in libya
this is not somebody that germany should
be getting into bed with and it's worth
remembering that the green light finally
for north stream 2 was given by germany
in 2015 that was after crimea that was
after putin started the wars in eastern
ukraine and they still went along with
it so they went into this with sort of
eyes wide open and i don't think you
know a few apologies here and there can
really
you know make up for what was done here
because essentially and this is what i
argue in that piece
germany opened the door for this they
effectively encouraged putin because he
felt clearly that he wasn't going to
suffer any repercussions from germany by
doing this it was also a strategy by
russia and it really made it i mean it's
not it was not only criticism from
outside but also inside we always
criticized it and i remember also that a
lot of politicians just laughed and said
well you're wrong because we criticized
from the energy point of view that we
have huge geopolitical risks if we do it
in that way and they were just ignored i
mean at laughed away let us let us take
a deeper dive just just one small
footnote we are all on germany right now
and that's right to do it and i'm very
much in favor of blaming everybody in
germany for for what they did with
energy policy but it's not germany to
decide how far pudding is going and what
kind of war he leads there's so many
more powers involved we have the
budapest memorandum
in 1994 when the great britain and usa
gave gave security sovereignty uh
assurances to the ukraine nobody's
talking about that so we have a lot of
countries involved in this and in fact
the eu at the moment is now debating
once again tougher sanctions on russia
in reaction to those devastating images
from butcher for example the idea of
embargoing russian fossil fuels is high
on the agenda germany and a few other
countries like russia-friendly hungary
have been resisting a full embargo at
least until now
in germany and in other european
countries entire industries have been
kept running on russian gas
there are plans to replace it with
liquid natural gas terminals from the
usa and other places but this will take
years
and an immediate suspension of russian
supplies would have devastating
consequences especially for the german
economy
hundreds of thousands of jobs would be
put at risk entire industries would be
jeopardized
the truth is that the sanctions that
have now been adopted are already
hitting many citizens hard and by no
means just at the gas pump
supply chains for the automotive
industry among others are already being
disrupted there is a shortage of
fertilizer as well as raw materials like
wheat which are usually imported from
ukraine and russia
all goods are becoming more expensive
because of rising transportation costs
and inflation is rising as well what
price are germans willing to pay for
ukraine
matthew even president zielinski has
indicated that he understands that
germany that germany can't go for a full
embargo on gas overnight as it were but
should germany being be doing more and
if so what
i think it should definitely be doing
more and i think the question is is the
wrong one i don't think it's what should
germany be doing for ukraine because
ultimately what they're doing is for
security in europe and i think when you
see these pictures
there is no other option from a moral
perspective but to impose a gas embargo
and yes that would be painful and yes
that would tip germany into a recession
but
do you really want to sort of live with
having funded
putin's aggression against ukraine and
let's remember there are hundreds of
millions every day that are flowing into
russia
for gas
from from germany
and uh you know i i just think it's it's
not going to be a legacy that any german
is going to be comfortable with if this
war as many people fear uh continues for
you know possibly years
malta
cutting off funds for russia's war
machine as it's been called is one of
the reasons given uh for uh saying that
germany and the rest of europe should go
for a tougher embargo but another reason
potentially could be that if putin is in
fact now planning to try to firm up his
control over the east because of gas
reserves wouldn't an embargo send a
message to him saying uh doesn't matter
because we're not going to buy them
i think we have to differentiate between
coal
oil and gas
coal and oil could in principle be
substituted just a question of money
there is an international market uh
there are different kind of ways to to
bring in coal and and oil from other
space gas is is much more problematic
because we are very much dependent right
now still on gas
i say if if germany would be willing for
example to frack to use the fracking
system
we can produce uh gas by ourselves in
germany
but there's a european ban on fracking
because
right now we are we're importing uh
fracked gas from the lng so-called
liquid natural gas from the united
states which is the result of fracking
so we are not shy in taking these gas
but we are very much reluctant to do it
just like germany's not shy in taking
nuclear power produced by neighbors
let's go to the energy expert here with
two questions germany's new economy and
climate minister who is a member of the
green party and certainly not
responsible for the predicament that the
country finds itself in he's been
working tirelessly to try to begin
weaning germany off of fossil fuels
making deals in the united arab emirates
and qatar to get more liquefied natural
gas looking to reduce coal he says that
germany can actually be off of coal and
oil by the end of the year so question
would be you have said you think germany
could do a full embargo even including
gas
how so
we did several studies especially on the
gas market we don't have to frack that's
the good news we can import it also from
other nations
liquefied natural gas of course is one
option and this is because we have
delayed the energy transition and the
new
economics minister green party one needs
to get other sources from a gas all over
the world that's for sure but we have
enough gas on the international market
it's always a matter of price and we
compete here with asian countries but we
can make it and we should make it i
completely agree with matthew we should
do it now
because it's it's
possible and to avoid this negative
economic impacts we can also do a lot by
helping the economy by helping also the
chemical economy we did that during the
corona
time so the government itself has it in
its hand
how to reduce the negative potential
economic impacts and this is why we have
to we did all the studies related to
energy or markets and it's feasible we
have to do it
melter how much hardship would the
german people be willing to tolerate
recently the economist said europe and
germany are asking too little of their
citizens that if they would simply turn
down the thermostat and drive their cars
slower we could reduce a lot of
consumption of gas
are the germans willing to do that or
that they just want to keep
in their complacent and comfortable
world it's very much the question who is
the actor if if putin decides to put off
uh
to pull by himself stop uh exporting gas
oil and coal to here i think germans
will understand that they have just to
suffer because what can they do if he
decides upon
if schultz the bundeskanster decides the
chancellor decides to to stop it and
it's something else because then their
own decision he made us
uh freezing in winter times or made uh
everything's more expensive and so on
and so on and i think this was that was
uh fueling their own frustration their
tendency to frustration what is i mean
the whole discussion reminds me
something of the late donald rumsfeld
and his famous expression there are no
knowns and known unknowns and unknown
unknowns we just don't know what kind of
effect an embargo has on the war he's
fighting right now we have the moral
obligation i understand this completely
and i share that a lot we and but and we
still don't know what what the
implications would be for the german
economy you have your studies the
chancellor has its own study by talking
about mass unemployment and mass poverty
matthew when you hear chancellor schultz
speaking to the bundestag as he did
recently in a debate about the budget
and outlining all the dramatic
consequences that an embargo would have
he referred to it as being catastrophic
is that the new leadership that many of
us expected from germany after his
speech on february 27th when he
announced an epochal shift
well quite frankly no and i i think you
know this is why looking back this whole
talk of this
titan vendetta as they call it in
germany this this shift
um you know i think we're going to have
to look closely at that
in a couple of months and see how far
germany is really willing to go also in
terms of military spending this is
already
starting to be questioned by many in in
in berlin in in the political debates
does germany really want to spend 100
billion on defense now was this just
sort of a knee-jerk reaction um i think
though that you know the germans
hopefully will settle on a position that
they won't regret
five or ten years down the road as they
are now regretting their position
towards russia because quite frankly i
think that yes there are a lot of
unknown unknowns i don't think that a
gas embargo is going to you know break
putin's will it won't but you know he'll
find ways to sell that gas to the
chinese to the indians and others but at
least it will not be europeans financing
uh this war and i think it's worth
remembering that germans western
europeans live very comfortable lives
people are not willing to suffer quite
honestly but i think you know it's worth
looking at what's going on in maria
poole what look at the people coming out
of those sellers and the stories they're
telling and i think uh you know it's
it's time for a reality check and malta
let's come back to our title because it
asks whether russian war crimes whether
those pictures from mariapol where we
see
emaciated hands and arms reaching out
for bread that was being distributed
after people came out of their sellers
will they change german minds our title
asks us russian war crimes uh end of
german illusions
i'm a little bit more optimistic than
matthew is i think it changes a lot we
see these pictures and i think
if it comes germany confronting their
own paths they dealt with the genocide
with genocidal intent with things like
this and they always had they had the
saying that this gives us an obligation
to stop it
and
i think if you take just take them by
words
you can change their their attitude
towards uh
things that are happening on the ground
claudia
in many ways it now looks as if the
period since 1989 uh
is ending and that we're seeing germany
and perhaps many others in europe as
well coming out of a kind of a bubble
where people thought that
we were surrounded by friends and good
commercial relations would ensure peace
and security
do you think we're going to see a new
real politic a new realism now in
germany perhaps especially when it comes
to energy well i would hope so i would
say welcome to reality because a lot of
experts also us but many others have
always warned against especially this
russian policy related to the energy
sector so there are so many geopolitical
risks related to this so i would hope
there will be a new real politic
related to the energy transition and
move forward to increase the share of
renewables and energy savings
thank you very much thanks to all of you
for being with us and thanks to our
viewers for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you